and we are back live from gamespot stage
show here at e3 2014 and these two guys
to my left if you
know anything about halo you know i
think about 343 industries you recognize
dan nyu and frank o'connor so excited to
have you gentlemen up here on stage
especially after you're showing at
yesterday's microsoft prep conference
welcome thanks matt great to be here i
saw a lot of halo stuff and we're going
to talk through all of it today during
our live demo we got master chief
collection we got nightfall we got halo
5 guardians and the beta uh
dan where should we start i'm a little
overwhelmed all right well why don't we
start with the collection okay all right
yeah i mean digging in so yeah obviously
yesterday we're really thrilled to be
finally be able to announce this thing
we've been working on so the master
chief collection is all four master
chief games so halo 1 halo 2 halo 3 halo
on one disc
um with one interface so you're
basically you can move through them
however you want we've unlocked all the
chapters at the beginning so you can hop
through it however you want now if you
want to jump in and play all through one
altar too et cetera you absolutely can
but the interface lets you hop around
however you want and it also lets us
create some playlists which is another
thing i'm really excited about like play
all the warthog missions all the tank
missions uh stuff like if i know
anything about you guys than the way you
like to curate things i'm imagining some
sort of developer suggested playlist
maybe coming down the pipe at some point
good job
but we're also i mean we've got 10 years
of fan feedback to to sort of dig into
as well so we you know as sergeant
johnson would say we know what the
ladies like
and i gotta say yeah watching sort of
navigating around and seeing the way
that's structured it just strikes me as
such a great way to sort of approach
these games with like that that archival
mentality almost that which is something
that you don't really see a lot in this
industry is how are these games being
preserved how are people able to
continue to play these games long after
they've come out yeah i think that's a
great perspective and that's the
perspective we really attacked it with
from a team right we wanted to make
something magical something special
and i mean really swapping a bunch of
discs out of a box didn't feel magical
and special to us so well speaking of i
am now having a flashback to that
magical moment
yeah a second weapon came up on screen
and then bam those smgs uh so we're
starting off we're kicking off halo 2
here and uh now just to clarify you guys
did
an awesome job on halo combat evolved
anniversary edition or just anniversary
and is halo 2 getting that full
treatment yeah and you just saw it right
now so we just switched to classic mode
so you know that was a big part of it
that you know people really enjoyed and
we wanted to keep that so
any point during the game you hit that
back button and the graphics will switch
to how they were 10 years ago as you
notice now we've got more power to work
with with the xbox one there's no delay
remember it used to like fade in and
fade yeah
it was really quick
yeah and that the thing that struck me
about that was
you know obviously the the lighting
effects and the detail in the
environments is striking when you
compare it to what it was 10 years ago
but at the same time that those those
geometric designs the lines of those
environments that artistic design
seeing the through line of that stuff
it just makes it made me certainly
appreciate what a great job you guys did
the first time around yeah i mean a
testament to what bungie built in in the
first place really strong character
designs really good aesthetic and it's
just been kind of a pleasure to go in
and give it a little bit of next-gen
polish and uh and actually halo 3 and
halo 4 both show up really well at 1080p
at 60 frames a second and there's a lot
more on screen than you think like it
made a really big difference
so what was you know what was one of the
biggest challenges or sort of was there
any uh sort of tough points something
you guys really wanted to got stuck on
or like had to work extra hard at to
really make it shine how long have we
got for this trip
let me tell you about the past two years
of my life
um honestly i mean i think two things
some of which are um they're somewhat
linked first of all was that that
interface that we were talking about
right because there was so much content
when we dug into it right these four
games over 100 multiplayer maps right
everything running on their original
engines
like how do you bring this together in a
way that it's it's able to the player
can understand that it's easy to get
through and it just feels special and
really i mean we're still working at it
right i mean really nailing that that
interface that ui has been a massive
task but um it was funny when we started
talking about it at a conceptual level
it was one thing and as we started
showing it to people and people really
saw how powerful a tool we were putting
in the hands of the player with that
interface just everything just clicked
very cool now that was a glimpse of halo
2 of course uh halo ce anniversary are
you have you guys basically just taken
that your work there you haven't had to
do a lot more on it or to kick it up to
the xbox one level have you gone back
and put some more stuff in it it's a
huge technological challenge i mean
you're not it's not like you're just
simply recompiling it for intel
architecture from powerpc um so there's
a lot of work goes into even the
simplest parts of it but i think to
dan's point it's it's the way that we
sort of connected all the pieces
together that was probably the biggest
challenge both in terms of the interface
and the extra content that's in there
there's six remade maps from certain
affinity in a new completely new mode uh
there's the halo digital series and
there's uh the new blur cinematics and
in halo 2 anniversary uh there's a ton
of new stuff as well so you got the
cinematics got the updated treatment in
halo 2 as well yeah the entirety of the
cinematics being redone by blur and uh
yeah they already looks those are the
guys you used for halo 4 right we used
blur we used for uh halo wars for halo
wars people loved it with cg's
automatically so incredible yeah and the
original cinematics are still there they
you press the back button and you'll
switch between the terrorists
all the audio with skywalker orchestra
yep so the same thing so when you hit it
so we've recreated all the uh recorded
all the audio all the weapon sounds and
that transitions too so you go back it
sounds like it did 10 years ago you hit
it and you've got new weapon effects new
audio we've re-recorded with the
skywalker orchestra i mean yeah it's
it's mind-blowing and i can't believe
you guys are gonna have to do it all
again when you put it into virtual
reality in five years
all right uh honestly i could
i want to talk a little bit about
multiplayer before we move on to some
more halo news because you guys really
talked about a lot of stuff yesterday uh
but multiplayer over a hundred maps over
100 multiplayer maps so quite literally
any map that is ever shipped for halo
one two three or four is in this game
and they run on their original
multiplayer engine so are you gonna make
that work man
so if you launch a halo three map it's
gonna run on the halo 3 engine you
launch a four map it's going to run on
the halo 4 engine so they all run on
their original engines as well and as
frank alluded to before
in addition to all of that we worked
with um certain affinity and created six
i caught we chose six iconic halo 2
multiplayer maps and recreated those on
a more modern engine so yeah it is a
massive multiplayer collection and is
this one of them we see ascension here
this is a perfect example oh god it's
like i get to watching this happen and
like it it's almost like that sense
memory i don't even know that i have it
but all of a sudden i'm like you should
go this way yes and like i'm like hold
down x to pick up the weapon while you
walk over that spot because don't even
break spread you know like
oh
so good so many memories and i have no
idea how you're gonna
manage to shift through all the people
who want to play all their favorite maps
from the choices of a hundred to den's
point that was one of the challenges but
i think there's a couple of things
working in our favor one is obvious
matchmaking and democracy are going to
decide what people want but we have full
support for custom games and one of the
things you don't really think about
because we're two generations later the
xbox one just has a lot more tools for
connecting players and friends with each
other socially you know alerts and
notifications and stuff so it's not
going to be hard to find your game of
choice and it's going to be fairly
trivial for sort of you remember lan
parties with halo 1 you're going to be
able to recreate a little bit just by
manually getting together with your
friends using the tools the xbox one
gives you for that stuff excellent uh
one more before we move on to some other
halo stuff that ranking system from halo
2 was not a continually gain rank type
system it wasn't uh the more you play
the more xp you get you level level
level up
you could lose rank and that created
uh
some moments that i'm not proud of in my
household as well as something i am
proud of when i when i gained one but uh
you know how are you guys doing the
ranking system is it sort of more in the
the recent vein of halo 4 so yeah the
ranking said we're getting a lot of
questions about that obviously right
because
that was pretty pretty awesome um we're
going to be talking more about how we're
attacking the ranking system as we uh
get a little farther down the line fair
enough all right so that's halo the
master chief collection uh slated to
come out this year november 11th
november 11th
almost exactly 10 years i'm gonna have
to play all those new games that are
coming out in october really quickly
then
but you guys also have other halo
projects in the works one of them was
nightfall which talked about yesterday
an original content original tv series
not the spielberg one but a different
one this is in in some ways kind of the
spiritual successor to forward on to don
yeah um it's happening at a bigger scale
we're working with ridley scott and
sergio mimika gazan
i actually just got back from one of the
shoots and i'm going back out there
again next week um
we built some
life-size halo things and it was it was
amazing to be in them and around them
and uh and we have an amazing cast and i
think it's it's a logical evolution of
what we did and forward unto don and i
think fans are going to be impressed at
what's up there on the screen ridley
scott and his people really know what
they're doing so
and so uh what is the setting of it
again have you
are you telling us stuff about this or
as you saw in the trailer that we showed
at the keynote there was a mention of a
guy called agent locke
in some ways this is kind of his origin
story you're going to find out a little
bit about his background um it's not
essential information for going into
halo 5 but it'll give you some really
good background on someone who's going
to become a very important character in
that now speaking of halo 5 of course we
got that cryptic giant sand bird thing
last year and the dramatic master chief
hood reveal this year uh not so much
showing guardian stuff as like
you know alluding like showing that
spartan what was his what's his name
agent locke agent lock
in that time frame yeah and that in that
time frame oh man you are you are
treading on some serious like
tips of icebergs here frank i don't know
how you're doing it makes sense and i
think uh
to your point uh we didn't we didn't
really focus on halo 5 guardians uh at
our keynote but the good news is you'll
be able to play it this year in the beta
so
yes and that beta starts
like this here this damn it's this here
i was trying to
it'll be late this year
all right so halo 5 guardians beta later
this year and of course with that will
come a lot more knowledge about halo 5
guardians just because we're going to
get some get some hands on it and stuff
like that like we we never got the
chance to do a beta for halo 4. the
schedule was compressed and we're going
to use this as a way to get real
meaningful feedback from from players
and it's a small small segment of our
multiplayer experience arena balanced
equal starts it's going to be uh in some
ways kind of old-school halo but you're
going to see some new features as well
interesting which of course spins off
all these questions about well if it's
an equal start what does an unequal
start look like and you know i'm having
invasion mode flashbacks and all this
stuff but
i gotta get it under control you guys
can't talk about that stuff now but i'm
very uh obviously excited to see a lot
of halo momentum i mean when 343
industries was founded you guys sort of
had this mandate to take take on the
huge universe that is halo and
a couple projects in is it is it great
to see so much stuff now continuing to
to come to fruition
yeah yeah it's been fabulous i mean
slow and steady right i mean we've been
you know slowly growing we've been
trying out some new things and we've
been getting great feedback from the
fans and the community and you know it's
great that they share our passion for
you know for what it is we're doing and
where we're going
well
they're not the only ones guys i'm so
i'm so glad you came on here to talk
about halo all things halo the master
chief collection coming out november
11th and then uh nightfall do we know
when uh that's going to become available
for yourself to watch it the day you buy
the game
you buy the game which
yeah all right very cool and then halo 5
guardians look forward to beta news
later this year dan frank thanks again
for coming on the stage i hope the show
goes well for you and i will try not to
follow you around and extract more halo
details from me the whole time all right
folks we are going to head on over to
sony's booth now they got a bunch of
games on display there ranging from
those really cool little indie titles to
the massive aaa ones you saw during the
press conference yesterday we're going
to take a look at a few of the aaa ones
this time around and then come back to
this stage for drive club